all right guys
bang bang i've got zubin here super
excited to uh to have him come on
uh i am a small investor in the company
he's building but
uh he's a fascinating guy so thanks so
much for uh for doing this man
oh thank you for having us i really do
appreciate it yeah let's jump right into
your background i think that you
um you're building a technology company
today but you you've got kind of a
unique background for somebody doing
that so
maybe walk us through yeah i mean the
sad part when you talk about unique
backgrounds in finance i actually do
have a finance background
uh so we are a fintech company i'll tell
you a little bit more about that but my
background is quite frankly pretty
simple i'm an immigrant i came here to
study unsurprisingly economics and
finance
and went straight into the banking and
technology world
did a lot of time in investment banking
specifically
working with technology and financial
technology companies and
quite frankly when it comes down to
thinking about the idea that we're here
to talk about
a lot of the genesis came down with my
experience being an immigrant
literally not having a credit score
having to eat snickers at night when i
was waiting for my paychecks to come
through
all very true stories and then fast
forward i guess more than a couple of a
decade plus later i want to use that
experience and my learnings to actually
help solve
what unfortunately is a very deep
problem in our country
yeah and i think when most people hear
finance and wall street and banks and
all this stuff they usually think of a
very specific type of consumer they
usually have disposable income they're
making investments
kind of it's something that maybe you
would find on twitter or
on television the user base that you
guys are helping and the initial product
is really kind of finding product market
fit with is a very different type of
individual or family can you kind of
talk through
who is that user and maybe walk us
through just like what are the financial
challenges that they face on a
day-to-day basis that people may not
understand
yeah sure absolutely so look our users
the average american i mean people
forget that the average american makes
about forty five thousand dollars a year
lives but lives paycheck to paycheck we
have a hundred million americans the
wealthiest country in the world
has a hundred million americans living
paycheck to paycheck and what that
fundamentally means is that they are
living in financial stress
can you imagine like having to go to to
mcdonald's for an example and having to
check your bank account to make sure you
don't overdraft and pay a crazy fee
so literally our user base is that 100
million americans making approximately
the average amount
they are spread throughout the country
california is the largest state with
texas in terms of the number of uses
and guess what the population and the
average american is about 30 years old
which again
looking at everything that we've talked
about is the core use that we
we here to serve we're not here to serve
as you pointed out
the twitter profiles the millionaires in
fact millionaires are useless they will
find our product completely
a waste of their time and money but on
the flip side for the larger population
that we have
we actually serve a deep need the the
second part of your question was
you what apologize what was the second
part of the question
just what are the kind of the financial
challenges that they face on a
day-to-day basis yeah sure
look financial stress right so our goal
here is to to target
what we can do to help people reduce
their financial stress the name of the
company is bridget
which basically means you want to bridge
your gap between your financial now and
your financial future
so what are the main reasons why this
segment of the population actually has
that financial stress
it's pretty simple if i'm getting paid
in two or three days and my
my bills come today that's a serious
worry right i want to make sure i have
money to pay my bills quite frankly if i
have kids i want to make sure i'll be
able to feed them these are not
unreasonable
requests especially if you're a hard
working american which most of us
are and i'm getting paid in three days
that stress
leads to a bunch of crazy crazy fees
which your historical lenders and quite
frankly the banks that we all
bank with take advantage of one great
example is the overdraft fee which if
you think about what that means in an
apr perspective like your credit card
for example is about 20 30
apr and overdraft is a 5 000
apr we have 30 million americans
approximately spending almost a thousand
dollars a year
in these fees on average it is insane
so that kind of fees really add up and
we've seen
in our user base we've helped our users
save about 500 annually in those fees
but whether it's late payment fees
overdraft fees all of that caused by
financial stress
is a problem the second thing that that
that is important for our user base is
eventually being able to save
and sixty percent of the country has
less than five hundred dollars in their
bank accounts
that's a problem not to mention being
able to build someone's credit score
so all in all i'm sorry i'm rambling a
little bit but it's
the core problems is making sure our
user base
and this segment population has access
to money today
especially if it's just waiting four
days or whatever it is to get paid
make sure that they can eventually build
a savings and not have to pay these
crazy fees
and obviously fundamentally important
for people's credit in the future
is improve your credit score yeah one of
the things i
remember you kind of talking through
when we first met was you said look
uh the craziest part is that the top
four banks i think was like eight
billion dollars off
overdraft fees uh but what happens is
they're not necessarily over drafting
people who
don't have the money it's just that they
don't have the money
on the right day right so it's it's for
people sitting at home who are kind of
wondering well what do you mean
it's something where uh on the 13th i go
grocery shopping on the 14th my car
payment hits on the 15th my netflix hits
and i and uh i don't get my paycheck
until it clears on
on the 15th right and so therefore
actually on the 14th or the 13th
i overdraft because i have the money in
the sense of
uh i'm getting paid and i'll be able to
cover those those bills
it's just there's a mismatch of actual
days right and so you can kind of very
quickly see
how you may actually get multiple
overdraft fees in a month
by simply having you know needing to go
buy groceries two days before you get
your paycheck and it causes this big
kind of financial stress then compounds
over time and you can get a really bad
place pretty quickly
yeah you're dead right quite frankly we
can get multiple overdraw fees and an
overdraft fee in the u.s an average of
35
in one day like we've got our use we've
got we've got
over a hundred thousand users who spent
over a thousand dollars in overdraw fees
just last year and exactly as you put it
it's kind of a penalty for not having
money
at that point in time with your bank and
the penalty is not a dollar here and
there like oh we'll help you out
the penalty as i pointed out is 35 per
transaction and it's very easy to have
multiple transactions
or multiple fees in the same day and one
of the things i think that also caught
my attention was kind of after you told
me about this problem
and kind of how pervasive it was i went
and i did a bunch of research right on
uh well how is it that the the overdraft
fees are actually getting
uh levied right and some of the things i
found were like
very very surprising and concerning so
things like if i swipe three times on my
card
and the first two purchases could be
covered by
uh the amount my bank the third one may
not but the third one's big enough
the banks actually sometimes can reroute
the sequence of transactions
in order to uh increase the probability
of
overdrafts and just some like very uh
nefarious type stuff and so
it just seems like this is a problem
that most people
don't even aren't even aware that that's
what the banks are doing yeah i mean
look
the reality is we have government
agencies that are meant to protect us
from that
uh unfortunately banks are sneaky
especially well i don't want to call out
anyone but
i'll call them out you use an example of
of
rescheduling or returning is what is the
technical term and quite frankly
wells fargo got fined 10 million dollars
and honestly 10 million dollars i know
it sounds like a lot of money for
for for definitely for myself but for a
large bank it's peanuts especially when
you're making
in the case of wells fargo two billion
dollars a year
from those fees and let's just be clear
that two billion
is not being paid by the twitter people
of the world even if they overdraft they
will give them more benefits
but it's being paid by the average
american and that's why overdraft fees
and if you talk about payday loans etc
all day long
the fact that it is quite frankly a tax
for the average american versus
people who are well off is just
fundamentally wrong and the profit
margins for these banks on overdraw fees
in particular
are absolutely through the roof we think
it's closer to 80 in many cases 90
profit margins which really shouldn't
exist in the world that we live in
yeah let's talk a little bit about
bridget and the product you guys have
built maybe walk us through kind of
if i'm at the average consumer i know
that i've been getting hit with these
overdraft fees i want to protect myself
i come in i sign up what do i get from a
product standpoint or what does it cost
me
yeah sure uh so so as i pointed out
earlier we had bridget here for
helping you specifically the average
american improve their financial health
in the specific example of the overdraft
all you really need to do is you
download the app
bridget.com or your app store or play
store
and we ask you some very few questions
including your name verify your
your cell phone number and we have to we
ask you to link your bank account which
is something that you've been doing for
example in mint
over 10 years almost standard many
fintech at that point in time we
evaluate your spending patterns
and we we're able to either and we don't
use credit scores very important because
we pointed out
part of the financial stress is people
not having good credit scores
another point in time you can actually
request for up to 250
assuming you're qualified and that's
sent into your bank account within
within two to three minutes if you so
want we
unlike other companies also have one
additional feature where you just turn
on the app
in the future and if we see that you
might actually run out
where those banks are going to make that
35 sneaky amount every single time
we'll pre-fund money into your account
so you don't have to worry about it
again going back to the financial stress
so besides this feature when we want to
help our users and we talked about the
problems
users or americans face the next step
there is we've
helped our users save over 500 bucks
annually
and and in terms of a business model or
we have a flat business model where we
charge
ten dollars a month no additional fees
there's no late payment fees there's no
transfer fees there's never an
additional fee
but besides access to the capital or
those automated advances that i just
talked about
we have budgeting tools that will help
you when you have money in your account
budget and extend it out in a more
responsible manner
we give you financial insights very
targeted personalized tips on what you
can do
to actually maybe save a little bit of
money or quite frankly earn a little bit
of money as well
through our jobs application and given
kovit what we saw
was we saw a lot of fraud specifically
in this segment of the population
so for the same ten dollar subscription
we're giving a million dollar identity
theft protection included in the package
that's what we're doing today so in
essence access to cash
when you need it uh especially to bridge
those evil fees
ability to budget better and the tools
that go with that and financial insights
including from financial literacy
as well as the fact that we're giving
access to uh the million dollar cash the
million dollar insurance that we just
talked about
yeah and what's so interesting to me is
like the technology you're building is
you really are having uh one a holistic
view of
uh these uh users right they don't have
10 20 different bank accounts and
investment accounts and all the stuff
like they literally are living paycheck
to paycheck with a single
account you have um kind of a view into
that and so you can be very very
accurate with understanding their
spending patterns the probability that
they're going to
go and swipe their card before they get
their paycheck like all of these things
that as you get better and better over
time for 10 bucks a month
if you prevent one overdraft fee each
month
they're already in uh kind of profit if
you will right if you think it from like
an roi perspective
yep i appreciate you selling us but
that's absolutely true
i mean it's fundamentally true right
remember what we talked about most of
our users don't actually end up
overdrafting once they end up
overdrafting multiple times in a month
and remember if you do three-time that's
already hundred dollars you're paying us
10 bucks you're
automatically saving 90 bucks not to
mention the the level of stress that's
reduced
i know i can't quantify that per se but
that's a fundamental game changer
on what you can do with the time and
mental well-being you can actually
budget better
you can actually go through financial
classes or spend more time with your
kids
in a stress-free manner if that's not
worth 10 bucks don't forget you have
those other other features
i'm not sure what is and and to add a
little bit more color
according to the omadr network which is
a philanthropy philanthropic
research organization according to their
numbers we're saving our users
500 a year in fees
and that is especially when you're
making 40 000
a year quite frankly you could be making
a million we think it's a lot
yup talk a little bit about kind of as
you solve this problem there's obviously
incredible demand uh for the product and
you guys done a great job kind of
onboarding those people and starting to
uh to save money for them
um how do you think about the rest of
the product suite right so you so
bridget is kind of
you described it in terms of bridging
people from where they are now to this
financial future
um i don't know how much you want to
talk about like other products you guys
may go build or other areas of that
financial stress that you think can be
solved with technology
yeah well i mean again so i don't want
to give away too much but let's just
talk about our our overall user right
again i
hate to say this this is most of us in
the country
we are living in this massive state of
financial stress by the way 80
of americans are in a constant state of
financial stress
that impacts our job it impacts our
overall mental health
etc etc so subsequently what are the
areas that we can target that can
that can have the best impact for that
we will still continue to be focused
initially on the fact that we'd be able
to bridge the gap between people's
paychecks
with the right amount of money at the
right time done in a transparent
reasonable and fair manner it's very
important those those principles are
very important to us
going back going into the additional
product suite we want to make sure that
the 500
we're helping users save in fees we
actually help them save in a bank
account
now i'm not saying we're building the
bank account per say but we want to make
sure that
we give people incentives in the right
manner to to continue to save
and that's important for their own
well-being how does that relate into
actually helping them build their credit
scores that's another area that we would
definitely be focused on in the future
financial literacy is is absolutely key
we're fortunate to have some well-known
investors including will smith and
ashley kutcher and kevin durant and
they've all signed up to do
some some content for us again
personalized for our user base so we're
looking forward
for that in 2021 absolutely
and so when you look at this segment um
it feels like
uh most people have said uh one
they're just in a different space
financially and it's very hard for
banks let's say maybe to uh to make
money there and so they used
to they're usually not the focus for uh
whether it's fintechs or banks or
whatever
you guys have built a very unique um
kind of business model here where for
that ten dollars a month you can kind of
continue to add all of these features
uh behind that subscription talk a
little bit about
um just the education as well right so
it's one thing to build
technology products and say hey here you
go this is going to
save you money or whatever but also i
know that you guys have done a bunch of
work around just like how do you
actually educate these folks are you
talking about
budgeting tools and some of this other
stuff and how important that education
is to to
drive people to change behaviors or do
the things that can get them in a good
position
yeah i mean i mean our thesis is
financial education
and literacy unsurprisingly is
fundamentally key but you can't force
feed that to people right it's just it's
that it's for speech
giving the right amount of information
at the right time similar to our other
credit product we talked about is
fundamentally key so if you overburden
someone who's already financially
stressed and say oh here's a two-page
dossier on how you can budget better
very few people are going to have the
time or the energy to actually go
through that
so we we look at the way we think of
financial literacy in bits and pieces
so for example right we see someone
saying hey
last week you spent x amount of money
and your dog on a particular item
and you yourself and personalized
believe that items
is an extra piece that is more like
luxury item
we politely remind you that we remind
you of that
there are other situations especially
what happened with govid where will give
you
specific insights about your own
spending so for example in the event
that you had
potentially lost your job or were in
volatile territory we would literally
know that you had an atn t
account or in my case a t-mobile account
and pop up a piece of content
and say hey here's a phone number you
can you can call it's a tnt
here's a small script and within 20
minutes there
you have 80 likelihood of them giving
your 20 discount or 20
discount on monthly actually so those
are some of the small pieces of
information
we want to give you at the right pace of
time over a period of time
as an individual starts to to save a
little bit more and have more cognitive
load
we do have more repositories already
available which are the
the one page summaries of what you could
do to actually do
to improve your financials another
example is actually
when you get paid so a lot of people
don't realize this
they can actually change their pay
schedule from instead of getting paid
randomly on a wednesday to a friday that
actually might have a
fundamental improvement overall in terms
of
normalizing their income and being able
to pay bills
better and on time yeah it's absolutely
incredible and i think that the
description you've used around this like
financial health app
right where uh you literally are taking
a holistic
uh view of technology education
incentives
um how does that evolve
with something like the macro
environment right so it's one thing just
to say hey we want to go ahead and we
want to solve the problem for
uh the folks that uh that we've
identified in this
user base but kovid obviously has had
the biggest impact on that population as
well so people are losing jobs
uh they're seeing their hours cut like
all these problems talk a little bit
about just
has anything changed or have you guys
kind of thought differently as
covid and some of the economic impact uh
played out sure i mean in terms of
thought
sought differently i mean the reality is
obviously this is a pandemic and most of
us are going through pandemic for the
first time
but we have gone through economic shocks
before even in my lifetime multiple
times
so what's happened for us and in many
cases is that this has just been an
accelerant
and a re-prioritization of certain
things so for example for us
is that we were very focused on building
content as we just talked about and
continue to be
we just had to accelerate more
actionable pieces of content earlier on
the other aspect of us is making sure
that the stability of our platforms
because
once governed you have a large number of
people 30 million americans who lost
their job
which pushes more people to products
like ours because they need volatility
being able to support that push becomes
fundamentally important so
the reality is in order to solve for
someone's overall financial health
that those principal components of
financial stress we've talked about
hasn't really changed
it's unfortunate in in any macro
environment that we've seen or we've
gone through in the past
the prioritization of what needs to get
done when that
indeed has changed yeah it's pretty uh
it's pretty crazy
um in terms of uh the pitch to uh to
users so people who are listening to
this who may be part of
uh the user base that could uh could
benefit from this what's essentially the
pitch that you have for them
it depends on the user but but in short
make sure you have cash when you need it
we don't look at fico scores in fact
anytime you have the level of stress
that you think you're going to pay a fee
come to us never go to a payday lender
they're in most cases horrible
your friendly neighborhood bank we just
talked about is horrible but
that's one area that we could help solve
the needs today but at the same time
if you want to truly improve your lives
from a financial perspective
not just today but looking forward as we
talked about
making sure that we can help you save
budget better
learn a little bit better and actually
over a period of time also improve your
credit scores
join us absolutely and then from a
company building standpoint
um any uh kind of needs there whether
it's hiring
uh or financing or anything like that
yeah fortunately on the financing side
we've got great investors like yourself
so i appreciate that and
and also the advice you give us uh so i
think we're good on the financing side i
think
hiring great talent is always is always
hard and very important to us
the only reason why we've had some level
of product market fit and been able to
help
over like almost 2 million users at this
point in time is because of the great
team
we are hiring at all levels so if you're
an engineer if you're in customer
service
if you're a senior or junior person in
operations give us a call
that's awesome i uh always end the
podcast asking the same two questions
to everyone and then you'll get to ask
me one to uh to finish it up
the first one is what's the most
important book that you've ever read
oh boy oh boy
and i knew that you would be very
thoughtful about your answer
shoot this is a this is a really hard
one
uh
can we go to the second question i'll
come back okay this the second one's
more fun
uh aliens believer or non-believer
let's put it this way uh and then it's
also a question of how you define
evidence
i am not arrogant enough to believe
we're the only
life form in this vast lost universe
uh hopefully that gives you an answer
i'm not saying area 51 or not but uh
hopefully that's an answer coming back
to your question all right
um you know there's business books
there's biographies where do you go
catch it on the right oh why that one uh
it it it there was no book
and also it's also also at what point in
time i read read this and what
my life was et cetera i think all those
things matter and
there was no book that i can i can
recall that made me feel
i don't potentially alive it made me
feel part of a book
than that book i love that answer
it it's uh it's like the personal
impact it has on you yeah right and i
think that's the part that's always so
hard
to kind of quantify or explain for
people and you know just thinking about
it i'm getting goosebumps
just going through the story in my head
because look it was also not set that
far
from new york and quite frankly in the
city i love
which is new york city that's awesome
you could ask me one question to uh
finish up what do you got for me
what do we do to make our product better
the you know what's actually crazy
you're the first founder to ever ask
that question on this podcast which is
mind-blowing but uh because probably the
most important question
um now look i i think that and you know
all this stuff but it's
just constantly trying to make it as
user-friendly as possible
uh and it's already i mean obviously
just given the user base uh many many
many happy customers uh but i think that
just kind of all of the little tweaks
um it's usually not the big product like
hey let's unveil this like
brand new thing that zubin thought up in
you know in the shower
uh and now he's gonna go and tell the
users they should use it it's
little things like can you remove one
click right can you
you know change a color scheme like all
the things that uh seem small
end up making a huge difference in the
user experience and you guys already
know that but uh but that's usually the
answers right
we appreciate you reminding us sometimes
it's easy to forget
like it's doing 50 things 50 times over
that's where you find our
the big improvements over a period of
time absolutely
where where can people go and uh and
download the app or or learn more about
what you guys are doing yeah sure you
can go
to either on the app store or the google
play store just type in brigit
again it's brigit or alternately on any
of your browsers brigit
dot com you uh you you could do live ad
reads on podcasts and you would be a
expert i i can't hey i don't have uh i
don't have a baritone
my voice is horrible for singing uh but
hopefully people haven't gotten too
bored
uh listening to me zubin thank you so
much for doing this i think people are
really going to enjoy it
sounds great